not much pedaling needed this bike zips
along at 25 km/h thanks to the electric
motor in the front wheel congestion
parking traffic tickets those problems
are a thing of the past for who bought
Villa whenever he can the interior
decorator leaves his van and hops on his
electric cargo bike model today all
especially at this time of the year
riding the bike through town in the open
air what a lovely moment in the morning
I thought about it for nearly a year I
wondered what I could do for the
environment but also how it could run my
small company more effectively and do
something for my health - you're
stocking a utility bike replacing a
delivery van the inventors are convinced
that they have found in Neesha the
market
they do maintenance work here in their
Berlin workshop the standard model of
their ebuy costs 3,700 euros most of
their customers use it commercially done
so much for chanson Figo's button we
have a chimney sweep from Bonn who
thinks it's great he can do his work
locally
I have a tree cutter in Hamburg who's
happy because he can drive his bike into
the park and in parking fond we get a
lot of messengers of course and people
tell us they can really save money with
this bike bike Austin's fond hope I
think la no longer worries about rising
gas prices he's been saving 180 euros a
month since he started writing the e
bike to work today the battery just made
it now he needs to charge it a full tank
costs around 10 cents but not all his
customers like the idea
in fact the interior decorator has lost
around a third of his clients since he
switched over to the e bike
Phil is intuitive summer bit perplexed
when you arrive on a bicycle the idea of
the car as a status symbol is still very
much present they often ask how I can
deliver or pick up the furniture to be
upholstered for them the bicycle is a
symbol well not of bankruptcy but a
frugality punish apart ISM and that's
not always an advantage in acquiring
customers yeah Nishimura knowledge but I
couldn't knock feyza but Winkler is
sticking to it and for most of his
renovation work he doesn't need a
delivery van honk mullah has sold around
100 bicycles like these it's still very
much a niche product many potential
customers don't even know that electric
bikes for transporting loads of up to
100 kilograms exist Deloitte Anderson's
of people first have to understand the
advantages of an electric cargo bike and
once it's established itself it'll be a
big market and even if some of his
clients have to get accustomed to the
site he is actually getting to his
customers faster than ever robot thing
club remains a committed electro biker